It's embarrassing to be independent, so I won't say it clearly
Also, looking this way is a pin 4
Emilia is embarrassed to close her eyes, but it's great, but in the
first place, what kind of situation is this?
Didn't I tell you that you don't have to do it now,
Subaru
, when you're exhausted, tell me to sleep on your knees?
You know, I can tell just by looking at you being overwhelmed I
'm sure you won't be able to tell me the details, right?
I'm totally fine, but when I'm in trouble Ichiku Aso
, look at this.  I was doing my best
[laughter]
Bubercon
I remembered that it was me, but my
heart was in the middle
I said I wanted to return
It was so bad
[music]
uh